good morning friends today is the last
and final day of our road trip and we
are all packed up
ready to go
with a narrow ass van which means
we gotta bounce we gotta go this morning
this guy right here
was
filled with piss so I had to make taika
pee in here
and these towels have a little bit of
kid piss and tuna to go because this
thing was flooded because Tyga didn't
know how to flush it because it's you
flush on the foot pedal here he just let
it sit we didn't know he had pooped in
the water slowly started leaking this
way so yes I'm talking about [__] water
there was [__] to water and I had to
pick it up
with these towels so
let's just close this
and pretend like nothing has happened
what are you doing we are back home
immediately put Tykes to bed because we
feel like don't have any scientific
evidence about this but we feel like
when tiger doesn't take naps or he
doesn't have proper sleep then it may
trigger
a seizure So to avoid any of that we
stick him to a very
um
rigid schedule of like every day he has
to take a nap anywhere between like one
to like two he needs to take a freaking
nap so right now it's 3 37 he's napping
while that was going on we were trying
to get Riley over there
and Mia to get along
but it didn't work it didn't work we
tried having them chase a ball we tried
putting them up back there in our
backyard where it's more of a neutral
spot because we just got Mia back maybe
two days ago
and so she doesn't she's not really
familiar with this space because prior
to that she was only here maybe a week
so she definitely does not consider this
her space so we were just hoping to be
neutral enough for both of them to get
along Mia's too rough and high energy
and Riley who the hell is that person
we doing over there
um I don't know who that is but
um Riley is just like chill out I don't
need this baby [__] energy step away
let me invite you into my space and this
chick doesn't know anything about
personal space so she said she's
absolutely stressed look at her ears are
back she's just like God damn what just
happened
what just happened to me I'm so tired
mom
this chick's like I just want a friend
but I got big paws and big energy
anyway the boys right now are taking
back the RV after the RV I think we're
gonna get some KBS but
we're kind of filling something with
veggies
because you know it helps us poop we all
need veggies in our life but if you ask
a Bart he's always like we get enough
veggies and Korean barbecue but they
give you like these little dishes of
like fermented
um
um pickled veggies which is very
nutritious it's good but it's not enough
so we're thinking more Shabu it's kind
of gloomy it's been raining it was like
slightly raining a little bit I mean a
sprinkling so we want something warm
with veggies for the poops so I don't
know what happened we'll see when the
guys come back I feel like we might end
up in Korean barbecue but who knows we
might look like that afterwards
getting the Korean barbecue
okay so Bart went oh sorry monkey did
you just bust a Lillian I was just
trying remember what Lillian did to me
you know what I was on my way out and
Lillian
smashed the door on my leg and then she
kicked my ass afterwards
no we're here to get Korean barbecue the
Shabu did not win tonight we are at
yuck
how do you say roja in Korean Yuka
how do you say Rojo you cookies
probably the right way to say it
hey come back come back
you're cutie you thought was the best
huh yeah
all right monkey what do you got here
Rock s yeah what kind of rocks
very beautiful one very beautiful ones
okay where did you get these rocks
my dad bought them for me yeah how many
do you have I'm 36. oh dude you have
names for your rocks
I don't know no names okay do you have a
favorite Rock
yes okay which one's the most favorite
rock that one oh oh that one can I see
them
where did you get these rocks that's
what they're missing
I bought earlier yeah
where did you buy this one earlier where
because right now we're in Nevada where
did you buy that one in Utah oh is there
one rock that's the most beautiful
yes which is the most beautiful one that
one oh my God that one is your favorite
okay which is the dinosaur egg too
which one's the most ugly one
that one the dinosaur egg you did
dinosaur egg is the ugliest one okay
which one's the funniest looking Rock
I would drop it don't do that anymore
don't do that you just dropped it on the
floor
okay we're done interview's over when
Bart and I get Korean food it never ever
looks this dope ready
look at all of this
so we don't know what the hell we're
ordering
look at all this David knows what to
order look at all this
oh my Lord
our table is never this pack I think we
only get like two different cuts of meat
I think mainly it's because your phone I
knew you were gonna blame me you piece
of [__] you should have jumped ahead of
it why are you so slow
[Music]
I think you're a little bit out of focus
when you put your head right here so I
can get a little bit closer uh a little
bit closer
so we just ate here
as I showed you before and um David and
mayor about to drive back home it is
like 6 30 right now so they need to get
coffee before they hit the road because
they're gonna be driving late night
she's like I want to get some coffee so
we started yelping we looked and she's
like huh it's a one minute drive
it's called Little Avalon remember
I said it was here
and we were walking in a big ass Circle
and it's literally right next door like
we literally walked all the way around
like big [__]
dumases okay let's see what this place
is about I'm not getting coffee
okay one more minute okay
there's nothing I need to say other than
look at this
they have to only have three claws let
me see your feet how do you like your
feet good
hey Mia hi Mamas and
hey how can we keep calling Papa bark
one
bar bear face I'm gonna keep calling him
Bart bear face
I love this
oh my God
you better get them you better get
reload code I think this is the bear
that you cut off his feet he wants his
feet back
oh
okay I do not exist I understand I do
not exist so as they play I'm organizing
everything trying to put everything away
washing our sheets getting some laundry
done because tomorrow is Monday
and I really do like to prep everything
on Sunday so that I have a really good
start of the week or just yeah because
the start of the week is really good
then the rest of my week will be really
good while I'm doing all that I bought
this a couple years ago I don't even
know how this really works
um I was trying to look for instructions
and I don't know if I threw them away if
it just didn't come with any because
it's that simple so when we were in Zion
I could love jumping into puddles so of
course naturally he went into a bunch of
Puddles and snow and just wrecked these
boots from the inside like this is
drenched like
all of these are drenched they've been
like this for a day already plugged it
in I thought it was going to be like a
blow dryer effect but I feel it getting
warm here so what I'm assuming is gonna
happen it's gonna get really really hot
Heat's gonna rise and I guess it's just
gonna
get hot on the inside of the boot I
don't know how it's going to dry the end
part of the boot
but hopefully taika didn't just ruin
these boots
because these boots are so red they're
waterproof I know it's funny that it's
waterproof and I got water on the inside
so you can imagine how deep into the
water bare feet
the bear man had to go
in order for this to happen the honestly
he was just like diving into these these
puddles
if you want to see what that looked like
check out yesterday's video because you
see how this happened so yeah as a
result of that we're trying to figure
out if we can salvage these boots or not
and Mia
how we doing
how we doing Mia you like it here
have we been good to you
oh the boy's back
see you later bear bear feet
you literally have bare feet
those are also bare feet yeah they're
bare feet
really leave me alone no don't say leave
me alone did you get your bushy Mister
you're gonna go to sleep
[Music]
hey
how do you like living with the quants
oh
should we start over okay
come on I mean
I just called her
phone is your name fun
was your name ever fun
in any of your past lives okay Sid if
you're ever fun
just kidding I know you just sat because
you heard the word [__] you wanna smell
that you wanna smell that yes yes
[Music]
oh you good girl you good girl you good
girl Mia is the most beautiful dog
that ever lived and he has a big snuggle
bug homie
oh my big girl
see you later
come here snuggle bug
should color snuggle bug Mia
whoops I can't believe I called her
fawn
she has she's so sweet like My Little
Pony
I wish I would have raised him a little
funny hey
you sweet girl
anyway friends on that note
I'm gonna call it a night I'm so
exhausted
his papa was driving the RV
[Music]
um I was in the back with Marion Tyga
and taika is
a handful
constantly going no stop this that
engaging in conversation playing games
I could see why people have more than
one kid
it's a lot of work and taika is such
a ball of energy and so smart and so
creative so he wants
to do a lot of stuff and needs a lot of
stimulation
I don't know why my throat just started
tickling
but before I finish what I'm about to
say check out my view
this right here
[Music]
brings me so much happiness
look at that
and literally right next to her
brings me so much anxiety so let's Zoom
back in here
yes
okay so what I was saying is
I'm tired
but it's okay
I'll get to sleep now
wake up tomorrow
Monday
then Tuesday taika starts his new school
let's hope that goes well
I don't know man this kid is so unique
he's so special
see a handful he is
such a half one I'm sure
you know you've recognized how different
this boy is
so blessed to have him in my life for
sure
but 2023 is going to bring a lot of
really positive change in my life
um
you know a lot of taikas
health issues
um
has been my number one priority I just
need to get to the bottom of it and
figure out how I can get my boy off of
medications or at least get him on the
right one that's not messing with his
mood and has all these crazy side
effects
get them off as soon as possible I'll be
as strict as I need to be I mean I have
no issues with
doing any type of ketogenic diet which
was invented
for people with epilepsy
weighing every [__] piece of
anything that he puts in his mouth I
don't give a [__] just whatever it takes
for him to get back to not having
seizures I hate that my boy
takes medicine
without squinting or making a face you
know what I mean like
growing up we hated medicine because we
weren't used to it and medicine tastes
like medicine it's disgusting it's not
supposed to be something that you enjoy
you know
and because we took it so rarely
at the at the mention of the word
medicine we're already trying to hide
from our parents so they can't find us
to make us consume this god-awful flavor
but this kid
every morning
oh
twice a day
we'll take it like a goddamn man like a
shot like he's had such a [__] hard
day and he goes
you know wherever we're he's taking in
the kitchen counter on the table he'll
slam it down and he just walks away in
the beginning he would need a chaser
like water or something so he doesn't
taste it but now
to the point where he just takes a swig
moves on with life
and I love that he's able to just adapt
so quickly but I hate
that he has to take it
but it is what it is and I try not to
think about it and I try not to get into
the space because it's so unproductive
but I bring it up because I know 2023 is
just he's just gonna be my major number
one priority and I'm so excited for that
even though I'm like here
I'm super excited for that because
finally I get to invest
way more uninterrupted time with my dude
you know and really be
the moment I wish I had even though my
mom's phenomenal I [__] love my mom
but you know
every generation you hope that the next
one is better than the last
so I I'm gonna take everything that I
love about my mama and
and add my own little flaring twist to
it and hopefully be better you know and
I hope
you know when daika gets older he's just
a way better apparent than that what the
[__] is happening anyway
yeah New Year
even though that's never really meant
anything for me
I just see it as cool
I just [__] get it popping let's go
let's get it done
but it was nice this trip was nice
hanging out with David and Mary was
always so nice like
I'm so grateful for the friends I get
to spend time with where
I can just turn my brain off it's the
best
oh
anyway I got so emotional when I didn't
even want to get this emotional
I just love my little dude so much
so tell my parents out there
if you're going through some [__]
dude that just goes to show you how much
you love every parent I mean you love
your kids which means
you're a [__] good parent so keep
doing that [__]
but yeah that was really nice it was
really nice
being out of Nature and connecting with
friends and just
it was not even connecting with friends
honestly it's just
living in the moment
good people you know and right now
I feel like a lot of us are so
disconnected from that
and we're just so busy with work and
there's just so many distractions that
you know any chance I get to just slow
things down and be in the moment and be
in nature and just
spend time with the people I love oh
it's a [__] best doesn't matter how
successful you are how much money you
have how many accolades
achievements nothing can ever beat that
feeling
anyways friends I hope you're having a
beautiful day
kind of nice thanks for listening
it always feels so good to just speak
so again thank you for listening and if
you have the opportunity to just talk or
Journal just getting it out of your head
it's always really really therapeutic
for me so on that note thank you so much
have a beautiful day happy New Year and
see you soon